cuál es el área de la figura así que acá
abajo tenemos esta figura de uno dos
tres cuatro cinco seis siete ocho nueve
diez la dos y queremos saber su área
cuántos metros cuadrados cubren por
completo a esta figura y tenemos algunas
medidas que nos van a ayudar bastante
pero lo que no me ayuda mucho es que no
tenemos una forma fácil de sacar el área
de una figura de diez lados distintos
pero lo que sí sabemos es cómo sacar el
área de un rectángulo y eso lo vamos a
usar entonces lo que haremos es ver si
podemos encontrar algunos rectángulos
por aquí fíjate bien por acá tenemos un
rectángulo
es un rectángulo y bueno por acá tenemos
otro rectángulo este de aquí es otro
rectángulo bueno más bien parece un
cuadrado pero de igual manera podemos
encontrar su área y por acá también
tenemos otro rectángulo este de aquí
también es otro rectángulo así que
podemos calcular el área de cada uno de
estos tres rectángulos y así podemos
encontrar el área de toda la figura
completa así que lo que hicimos fue
romper o descomponer esta figura entre
rectángulos y ahora podemos averiguar
cuánto espacio ocupa este primer
rectángulo y cuánto espacio ocupa este
segundo rectángulo y también cuánto
espacio ocupa este cuadrado y si al
final le sumamos cada una de estas tres
áreas vamos a obtener el área total de
la figura es decir cuánto espacio ocupa
la figura original así que empecemos con
este
y si observas es de ahí tiene tres
metros de largo lo podemos dividir 123
metros de largo y de ancho tiene dos
metros así que si dibujamos estas líneas
te vas a dar cuenta de que tenemos dos
filas de cuántos cuadrados
bueno pues observa tenemos dos filas de
123 cuadrados es decir dos filas por
tres metros cuadrados o lo que es lo
mismo dos por tres
es seis metros cuadrados así que este
rectángulo tiene un área de seis metros
cuadrados o podemos decir que este
pedazo de la figura se cubre con seis
metros cuadrados bien ahora vamos a
fijarnos en el siguiente en este
cuadrado y si observas tiene medidas de
tres metros y tres metros así que
tendremos tres
de tres metros cuadrados tres filas de
tres metros cuadrados o lo que es lo
mismo va a cubrir un área de nueve
metros cuadrados y también podemos ver
este rectángulo de aquí este rectángulo
de aquí tienen medidas de nueve metros y
tres metros así que podemos decir que
tenemos nueve filas nueve filas de tres
metros cuadrados o lo que es lo mismo
nueve por 327 metros cuadrados
entonces el área de esta sección grande
que tenemos aquí va a ser igual a 27
metros cuadrados el área de esta sección
que tenemos aquí va a ser igual a 9
metros cuadrados y el área de esta
sección que tenemos aquí va a ser igual
a 6 metros cuadrados y ahora si
combinamos o sumamos todas estas áreas
entonces vamos a encontrar el área total
de la figura vamos a sumar cada una de
las áreas de cada sección 6 metros
cuadrados más 9 metros cuadrados
+ 27 metros cuadrados para obtener el
área total de la figura y bueno si
sumamos esto nos va a dar 6 y 9 eso es
lo mismo que 15 15 más 27 y ahora vamos
a sumar esto veamos una vez 5 más
una vez 7 57 es lo mismo que 12 muy bien
y después tengo una vez 10 más 2 veces
10 o 10 más 20 lo cual me da 30 30 más
12 y bueno eso es lo mismo que 42 así
que ya está el área de la figura que
nosotros buscamos es de 42 metros
cuadrados
metros cuadrados
y ya acabamos